概念の回転 ローテーションオブソーツということで
心に無数の思考のループが現れる
こういう時 次にループの問題に入ります
で これはこの一番大きい今日のテーマで
あの かなり知識を邪魔にするものなんですね
まあループということで
まあループというのはまあ一応コンピューター用語で使っている単語で
まあループって日本語で言えば何でしょうかね
え？うん 輪でしょうかね
まあちょっと道草するような感じで
言葉はね 家に直行で行かないで
ちょっとそこら辺に一回りをして
また元の道路にまた戻ってまた行くんですよ
だからループと言うんですよ
ループの場合は元に戻らなくちゃいけないんですね
寄り道ですね  寄り道ですね
ん？ん？回路 これでこの
これはどうしようもないんですよ
ループは必ず出来上がるんです
この寄り道したくないよと言ったっても
これは無理です 認識データが入るたびに
関連性のある過去の認識と合成して知識化するので
絶えず心の中で思考のループが現れるんです
これはもう現れます 何か認識
何か体にデータが入ったら
すっとループで回って認識するんです
だからまあコンピューターの働きと同じで
コンピューターの働きも同じっていうとあべこべですけど
人間がコンピューターを作ったんだから
それは心の働きなんです
結局は心で考えてやるんだから
だから より早く いろんなことを結果を出すためにどうすればいいかという考えたところで
まあ数学で考えて こういうこういうことになるんだよと
それはそのまま心の働きでもあります
心もそういうパターンで働くんです
ループ同士がつなぎ合わせることで
大きな複雑なループも複雑に出来上がる
そこで普通我々はもうちょっと鳥を見て
あ カラスだそれでストップはしません
別なループをたくさん作るんですよ
で カラス見たらカラスだと
で カラスだと言うためには
一つループを回路を回さなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
そこまでいいんですよ
別に そこまで起こるんです
必ずも それからなんて嫌な鳥でしょうかとかね
これは迷惑ですよとかね
カラスに餌をあげてはいけませんとかね
あれこれとか いろんなループが出来上がっちゃうんです
危ないんだと カラス危ないんだと
人を攻撃するんでしょうとかね
いろんなこと 攻撃されたことあるのかって
それでもないしね 攻撃されたことでもないし
カラスに攻撃したというニュースもないのに
なんでカラスに攻撃されるんだと言うんですかね
あれ 感情のループだからなんです
でなきゃかなり楽なんですけど
人生は だからカラスを見ただけでカラスを見るということはちょっとおかしいんですけど
この何かを見て 何かを見てカラスだと認識する
それでこのそこで一回ループは回転するんですね
それで終わらないんですね
それにつなぎ合わせて
いろんなループが 嫌な鳥だとか
私は大嫌いだとかね なんでもう石原さんが全部東京に住んでるカラスと処分しないのかとか
いろいろ人によってどんなループでも作られます
知識人は巨大な思考のループをたくさん持っているんです
そこで知識人というのは何なのかというと
一つのデータが入ると
それについてものすごい巨大
複数のたくさんループを回すんです
だから 何かについて一般人の語ることと知識人が語ること
それは違うでしょうね
例えばエジプトのね 博物館で何か持ってきて展示すると
ミイラだとかね で 我々はそれだけで終わりますけど
早稲田大学のなんとかの名前の教授がいるでしょうね
え 吉村さん うん その教授が見たらどうなるんですかね
すごい違うでしょ だから吉村先生が知識人だからね
もうエジプトの考古学の場合は
だからもう数えられることはできないです
持っているループの数は
知識人というのはそういうふうにまあたくさんループ持ってます
まあどうせ関連性あるループだからね
あまりそんなにね 大変なことでもないんですけど
吉村先生でももう納豆食べると
あ 納豆でしょってこれで終わるかもしれませんし
まあループ一回 二回でね
納豆の由来は何なのかよ
それあんまり考えないでしょうね
それよりはミイラの由来は何なのかと考えるんであってね
それでまあ 2種類ありますよ
良いループと悪いループという
まあそれも理性と感情
感情の問題ですけどね
理性に基づいてループはループは基づいたループはしっかりしていて
問題を引き起こしません
理性に基づいたループだったら
問題は引き起こしません
ただ エジプトの古いものを見ても
吉村先生は混乱するわけでも
頭がおかしくなって精神病気
病棟に運ばれることもないんです
理性ですからね しかし
こうだからこうなる ああだからこうなると
我々考えちゃうと もう薬を飲む羽目になるかもしれません
結論に達してから元に戻る
感情的なループは悪いんです
結論はない 同じ感情を強化する
また その感情で同じ思考のループを歩むんです
だから 怒りで何か認識したら
その認識 知識としてまた怒りが生まれるんです
そうするとまた回転してまた怒りを作るんです
そうするとどんどん感情が強くなるし
認識もどんどんきつくなって
どんどん固執した固い認識としてまた記録していくんです
これがもう精神病気ということで
明らかにそれで病気になるんです
すべての精神病気は 例えば何か見て欲が出てきたら
欲ですから 関連性あろうとなかろうか
いろんなものを考えて考えて
どんどん欲を強化していくんです
これが限りのない妄想の流れということになります
だからループで回るんであって
元に戻らないんですね
頭の中で妄想 妄想 妄想だけで回転する
ということで この妄想と思考というのは区別できます
で 論理的に必要な どうしても必要なループを回すことは思考であって
結論が出ますからね 結論出ないループは妄想なんですね
それはもう終わらないんですね
例えば あの人は嫌いですという認識は
感情的な非論理的な知識であって
悪いループからそれ出ちゃうんですね
それについて考えると思ったらいくらでも考えられます
いくらでも妄想できる
あの人は何者でしょうか？ということは論理的な質問でしょ
それで頭回転されてすぐ答え出る
あ そうですか それで終わっちゃうんです
あの人は実はこういうところで生まれた
こういう名前で この年で
こういうこういう会社でこういう仕事をしているんだと
ああそう それで終わっちゃうんです
結論出ましたから あの人は嫌いですという認識の場合は
ループは限りなく回るんです
そういうことで Bad
loop degenerate knowledgeということで
この悪いループは知識を退化させるんですね
欲 怒り 嫉妬 落ち込みなどの感情で認識でデータを処理すると
同じ感情が強化して現れるんです
外の情報を取り入れることなく
心の中で同じループを限りなく回転する
で あの花の例で考えてください
花を詳細に見たければ
じーっと見ればいいでしょ
時間かけてデータたくさん入れれば
感情で見れば バラの花はバラもあんまり好きじゃないや
あの色はいくらでも考えられます
時々ありますよね 見たこの大きなバラの花かもしれませんだけど
感情で見たならば 嫌やと
あんなちっぽけな花なんかはね
面白くもないと それじゃなくて
花というのは結構あるでしょうと
自分が大きいのに 頭の中で小さくさせてるんです
わざと そういう風にもかけ離れますよ
だから感情のループになっちゃうと外からデータ入れません
知識人だったらループは行ったんだけど
ちょっとうまく結論に達しません
場合はさらに探すんですよ
で エジプトの土地を掘ると何か破片が見つけたら
これって何でしょうかとわからない場合はさらに掘ってみるんです
あるいはいろいろ調べてみるんです
それ 知識的なループの場合は
新しいデータ取り入れてしっかりしたループを出来上がるんです
感情の場合 入れません
見ただけで十分です もう 10年ぐらい悩むために聞いただけででも
知識 能力 精神力がそれで衰えていくんです
データが入らないんだから
このループから抜け出ることはできないんです
感情のループできちゃうと
とても危険 もう相当無理
ガラスに落ちた蟻のような感じになります
ガラスといったらそんなでっかいものじゃないでしょうに
蟻が上がらないんですね
滑るんだから 例えば我々でもちょっとした穴に落ちたとしましょう
自分の背ぐらいの高さの
どうったことないでしょうに
しかし 手を伸ばして上がれますけど
全部すべすべだったらどうしますか？足をつけても滑ってしまう
手をつけても滑ってしまうんだったらもう終わりでしょう
どんな大胆な穴じゃないんでしょうに
例えば自分のせいか 手を挙げてもうちょっとあっても上がりますよ
穴に落ちたんだからって何のこともない
しかし その穴が 皆様生きてるビニールの箱のごとく
すごくスムーズすべすべだったらどうしますかと
上がれなくなっちゃうんですね
それで死ぬ羽目になっちゃうんです
だからこの感情のループができちゃうと
こればっかり回転するんですよ
回転すればするほど さらにさらにスピードを上げて上げて
さらにさらに強化して強化していくんです
心の中に同じ概念を繰り返し
限りなく記録される 精神病に陥った人は退化していく
脳にも体にも悪影響を与えるんですね
一旦悪循環の妄想回転に陥ったら
そこから抜けることはとても難しいので
徹底的に気をつけなくてはならないんですよ
これはものすごい気をつけないと
で 今日はそんなに難しくないんだからね
話はもう早く飛ばします
次に心とものの流れっていうことで
で これは内外アッベアッベアンタルバーヒラというパーリ語で言葉 2つあって
アッジャッタバーヒタという自分
内と外ですね で 心というのは内ということで
心が認識するんです だから認識する対象っていうのは外っていうことにするんです
心が心を認識するということは
まあ論理的には不可能です
心は心を認識する場合は
過去のデータを認識するんです